probably the most authentic feature of  joe biden's public performances has been  his anger that seems to come over him in  waves watch focus on this man  what he's doing that no president has  ever done  no president no i haven't taken the test  why the hell would i take a test  come on man  that's like saying you before you got in  this program you take a test where  you're taking cocaine or not what do you  think huh  are you a john what are you saying i'm  not out of time you spoke over time and  i'm going to talk here's the deal  the fact of the matter is  look at what's happening here well  that's not true you're saying things you  do not know what you're talking about no  one said that who  who  said  that  you said i set up my son to work in an  oil company didn't know what you said  get your word straight jack  [Music]  that's a great asset  more inflation